[Music]
I
uh tonight is the Emmy and Peabody
winning host of Last Week Tonight all
episodes are streaming on HBO Max please
welcome to the show
Traveler
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you hello
Oliver hello to all hello
hey John Oliver you're here because you
are the funniest smartest kindest late
night host there ever was your show
shines a light on injustices in this
country in a way that only someone with
an outside perspective can there's more
you have one
three gajillion Emmys and you deserve
each and everyone thank you for being
here I love you so bad that is
that is
that is an essay with I counted 12
inaccuracies it is but we did not have
time to unpack right now I will say this
I absolutely love this show I love this
show so very much I want that to be I
want there to be many more episodes if
if if Mr and Mrs peacock
if you're sitting at home chomping on
cigars in your tiny beaks
crazy not to pick this show up
if I ran
but if I run a network Not only would I
have a debilitating cocaine habit
first thing I would do is is get this
show onto my network it'll be you and a
mound of cocaine
yeah I love it so much thank you John
Oliver yes I love you so much now I have
a question yes you're from England true
but you live here now
the differences between uh
but you live
judgment in the tone now
living off our tax dollars
[Applause]
I'll pay you tax yours don't count
they're in pounds
what are the differences between a
British Christmas and an American
Christmas oh that's a good oh also you
have a margarita oh thank you very much
thanks
um that's a great question
um for us every Christmas morning there
is a kind of Victorian street urchin
waiting outside of our windows
to go and get us large turkeys
it's the original Uber Eats
um
uh no it's we are very very Christmassy
uh in Britain we love the Christmas
first we uh we bump butts under the
mistletoe everybody does
um as is tradition uh and yeah every
everything is sarcastically Christmassy
very shiny uh lots of Lights uh and it's
there for we go we go all out you guys
have that thing where you um the
crackers hey am I right
I I sound crazy oh oh crackers
um
I was gonna say that's
it's okay for us
[Applause]
it's actually not okay
I'm sorry yeah we do have a a very
cracky Christmas
um uh we do we have uh we have uh
crackers so they're like um minor
explosive devices yeah uh that uh that
you pull apart and then if you get the
big end of it you get a hat and a joke
and a toy yeah and if you get the the
little end of it you get nothing yeah
yeah I like that because that's how the
world works exactly okay yeah another
one of your Traditions is something
called mince pie what is it now I like
pie I can't I can't justify that what
this is this is the most Christmasy
thing in England it's a pie filled with
mince meat which is there's no meat it's
a like dried fruits and nuts and kind of
the peel of oranges soaked in brandy and
don't do that face don't do that face
I'm describing to you a very crack of
Christmas
all that and you kind of let it sit for
a while then you pack it into a kind of
Mound and then you separate it out and
then you put it in pastry you wrap it up
and you eat it I don't like the way it
tastes but I love the way it makes me
feel because what it makes me feel is
Christmassy in its full form I'm gonna
taste it do it is it gonna be bad no
well now I hate most Foods
now you you barely had any of the mince
meat there you need a bigger bite
[Applause]
there's jelly in here you said you take
the rhymes of an orange and you feel
this is
this is jelly there is the jelly jelly
it has a gelatinous
effect to it it isn't actually jelly it
might be the kind of boiled down marrow
of a pig
do you want to eat the other one I've
not had one this Christmas season yet so
I certainly will
and and what's happening in your heart
right now on my taste buds are saying
was never a good idea it never will be
my heart is saying
it was the World Cup one minute ago
that's true uh England got beat so bad
did you cry
I didn't I didn't cry because I expect
defeat
but I
did I did when we um when we lost my
wife did say is everything okay and I
just walked into a different room
I felt like my silence and that walk
probably said more than many words could
I remember once it was a previous World
Cups we got knocked out by Germany the
absolute nightmare
um and the same thing happened my wife
said are you all right and I walked
around Central Park three times
on my own
until the pain ebbed away to a
manageable level
very funny
yeah so hurt real pain yeah real Dutch
pain sorry sweetheart yeah because he
wants something and dreams of something
that can and will never happen never
gonna happen yeah I'm so sorry I'm sorry
poopy
um I first of all let's both lick our
lips for crumbs I was gonna say I'm I've
got a lot of mince meat jammed into it's
almost like a dip it's like a minced
meat liquor
yeah there now it's a clingy food stuff
if you can call it food
I choose natural
yes this is a real question and I want
you to answer it with your whole heart
okay all right the French national
football team and the British royal
family are both hanging off a cliff you
can only save one of them you can only
have them
who do you save
yeah
somebody got to die
someone's Gotta Die John I got I got a
follow-up question which members of the
royal family we're talking about
only the bad ones so I guess I can I can
narrow that question down is Andrew
there yes I'm saving the French
reluctantly
reluctantly and with no Grace and as I
saved their lives I'll be saying I
didn't want this and I need you to
understand
I wanted death for you and it was taken
away because Andrew was there you
understand
look I think you made the right call
um everybody this is John Oliver don't
you love him
[Applause]
well let's
let's talk about Christmas again okay
now as you've probably figured out I
love Christmas romance but it's always
been hard for me to decide what the best
thing about Christmas is now I'm
wondering if you can help me figure that
out in a little game called Christmas
madness yes
all right so let me explain what's going
to go down right here we have a holiday
bracket stacked with eight of the most
iconic things about Christmas now we are
going to work our way through this
bracket deciding which Christmas things
should advance and which should be
eliminated until we Crown one final
winner the winner we choose will
officially go down in history as the
absolute best thing about Christmas John
are You Ready never but I'm gonna do it
yay yeah okay let's do it okay first up
yeah the movie It's a Wonderful Life and
gingerbread houses I'm gonna go with
personally It's a Wonderful Life For Me
much more Christmasy
um
gingerbread houses seem like a good idea
and they never are I have never met
no one has
a Wonderful Life yeah I got here Amber
secret Santa or Christmas carols go okay
secret santa sucks but yes I could not
agree more I hate that too much pressure
no one likes people
so it's too much of a risk it's a
Russian roulette with presents yes that
so this is dead right yes Christmas
carols is alive yes we're right to tidy
up okay next up eggnog versus giant red
bows in car commercials I gotta say okay
love that [ __ ] do you really I love
him being a millionaire putting a big
ass bow on a car like it's a toy I don't
like to me this is a royal family French
football team situation something has to
advance and that either one is getting
knocked out but it's a Wonderful Life
eggnog isn't drink it isn't food I don't
know what it is yeah that I the idea
that anyone would get a car for
Christmas is really cause for class more
so
I'm going to
if you like you like the bow I like the
bow okay I'm gonna let the bow go ahead
but it's getting knocked out okay bye
it's a wonderful we'll see what happens
oh we will see
all right what do you got candy canes or
Christmas trees you go first
Christmas trees I'm not even so sorry
that is a terrible question I love
I love nothing is better than a
Christmas tree exactly okay
It's a Wonderful Life versus giant red
bows and power commercials I will
physically attack you if I try to make
the case
the bows on expensive items that
depreciate the moment that they're
driven off the lot you're giving someone
the gift of debt
a new car is never a good idea a boat is
not going to get you back up to level
think you understand how big the bow is
I've seen the boat the biggest bow
you've ever seen you can get a bow and
put it on your regular car Daddy okay
great great all right It's a Wonderful
Life advances so
Christmas carols for Christmas trees
I love Christmas carols yeah I love
Christmas trees yeah I need Christmas
carols if I had to go without Christmas
carols I would be sad right what
Christmas tree he the best that's right
what do we do tonight Santa I'm taking
my talents to Christmas trees
all right It's a Wonderful Life versus
Christmas trees let me just tell you
this
I don't care about it's wonderful
if long it's black and white and it was
before people had to keep this kind of
attention
I cannot do it
complaining
every time shut up
honestly I was instinctively ready to
defend this so much harder until you
brought America's racial history
and
I don't know man we got a hat trick of
very white faces
I'm gonna agree with your Christmas
trees does it yeah
[Applause]
it's Christmas trees
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]